Speaker 1: Remember that whole story?
About her emails, her being Hillary Clinton's
emails, I'm sure you can remember a Hillary
the story went in 2016 was so irresponsible
Speaker 2: by her
Speaker 1: use of a private email server that
she should not be president and instead it
should be Donald Trump.
In fact, they would chant lock her up over
her emails.
Speaker 2: Michael Flynn led a chant.
Speaker 1: Endless chants, lock her up, lock
her up, lock her up.
But instead, it is actually Donald Trump whose
administration
Speaker 2: was riddled with primitive
Speaker 1: private email servers, encrypted
messaging
Speaker 2: apps, her
Speaker 1: private email accounts,
Speaker 2: messaging apps and the like.
Speaker 1: The whole story of Trump will be
responsible with information.
Trump will be responsible with emails.
Trump will do it all the right way.
Have records for everything.
Presidential Records Act.
It was B.S., and we know that
Speaker 2: Ivanka and Jared
Speaker 1: were using personal email for business
related to their roles as advisers to Donald
Trump.
But now there's an even bigger bombshell revelation
on this exact issue.
We have now learned that Donald Trump's last
and final chief of staff, he had a few.
His last and final chief of staff was Mark
Meadows.
Speaker 2: Mark Meadows used year ago
Speaker 1: his own personal cell phone for
White House business one personal Gmail account.
A second personal
Speaker 2: Gmail account
Speaker 1: and the encrypted messaging
Speaker 2: app Signal,
Speaker 1: all four official White House business,
these people are pathetic and they're liars,
Speaker 2: but they win by doing this stuff,
Speaker 1: and I'll get to that in a moment.
This is all coming out now, along with the
PowerPoint planning the Trump coup, which
we talked about yesterday thanks to a 51 page
report from the House Select Committee
Speaker 2: investigating the Jan.
Speaker 1: six riots in looking at whether
to hold Mark Meadows in contempt., the House
put out a report detailing his different actions,
and this includes the revelation
Speaker 2: that Meadows was using Signal.
Speaker 1: The app is personal mobile phone
Speaker 2: and two
Speaker 1: personal Gmail accounts for White
House business.
Government officials
Speaker 2: are supposed
Speaker 1: to use government issued accounts
and services to communicate about their work.
They're supposed to forward private messages
to government accounts to have transparency
and accountability and to create a record.
Trump bragged about he would have the most
transparent administration in history.
And Meadows didn't do it.
Meadows is not the only one.
Remember that this was the reason Trump said,
Don't vote for Hillary in 2016.
But Melania Trump used private email.
Speaker 2: Ivanka Trump did it.
Speaker 1: It's a very, very long list of
people.
And yet nobody's chanting, Lock him up, lock
her up about the Trump family and staff who
did this exact same thing.
I haven't heard Trumpists demanding Mark Meadows
be in prison as a result of this.
They are nowhere because they don't actually
care about this.
When a
Speaker 2: Republican does that, and this
is one of
Speaker 1: the reasons they win, that's the
important thing.
The hypocrisy is not new.
Speaker 2: I doubt many of you are shocked
to hear
Speaker 1: that Mark Meadows was doing this.
Speaker 2: And of course, they are hypocrites.
We knew that.
That's not surprising.
Speaker 1: But another reason they win is
that they do this stuff brazenly.
They bend the rules on voting.
They bend the rules on everything they can.
They'll write new rules.
They'll throw rules out, they'll get rules
canceled.
They'll attack their opponents on any basis
they can.
And when it comes to them, they ignore it
all.
They ignore their values.
They don't apologize.
They don't even justify it to their voters.
And that's why they win.
They don't even go into the position of justifying
it to their voters.
They just ignore everything and is ignored
and they just power through, and they don't
care about being
Speaker 2: exposed as hypocrites.
Speaker 1: Democrats, on the other hand,
Speaker 2: and I get it because
Speaker 1: I don't want to be called a hypocrite,
I don't want to be a hypocrite.
Democrats actually try to avoid being hypocrites,
and when they are, they address it,
Speaker 2: even if it's to say it's defensible.
For whatever reason,
Speaker 1: Republicans don't do that.
So Democrats ultimately find themselves in
positions where the only way to proceed is
look like hypocrites and cop to it or play
just as dirty as Republicans in some way,
shape or form.
Understand that Republicans wanted to jail
Hillary for this, and tons of people were
doing the exact same thing in Donald Trump's
staff.
And they don't even pretend to apologize for
it or write it off as different.
They just plow through, and it's part of why
they continue to win.
How Democrats deal with that, I don't know.
Because as I've said before.
Speaker 2: Redistricting to pick something
Speaker 1: for a while.
Redistricting is going to be done in a Partizan
way.
Republicans will use it to their advantage
when they have an opportunity to gerrymander.
Democrats have to do the same.
Speaker 2: We have to change the system, but
Democrats
Speaker 1: have to do the same while that's
the system.
This other type of stuff demanding people
be extra, judiciously locked up when they
haven't even been accused of a crime because
of the revelation that they use private email
or whatever.
I get it.
We don't want to stoop to their level.
Their level is disgusting.
So what do you do to win?
I don't know the answer.
But this is a perfect, perfect example of
how Republicans are throwing very heavy stones
from week glass houses.
And yet nobody throws any stones back.
I don't know what the answer is, but I'm curious
to hear from a we we're almost at the end
of the year.
It's it's shocking, actually, that 2021 is
already almost over.
We want to start off 2020 to the it's an election
year and the election is going to start, I
think, quite early.
We want to start off with a bang of sorts.
As I've told you, we've seen a decline in
membership over the last four months of the
year.
A lot of people struggling financially, etc.
on January 1st, we are going to
Speaker 2: do a mid-term
Speaker 1: 2020 to kick off the year with
a bang
Speaker 2: membership blowout
Speaker 1: like nothing that has ever happened
before.
You know how Trump says it should never be
allowed to happen again?
Well, our accountant and lawyer are telling
me already.
Whatever you're doing on January 1st, don't
do it again because it's going to be crazy.
But we are going to do a wild membership discount
on January 1st.
Want to start off strong?
I would love for you to get a membership on
January 1st.
Speaker 2: You want to be
Speaker 1: notified of how to take advantage
of the insane, immoral discount we're going
to be offering.
Just get on my mailing
Speaker 2: list at join Packman
Speaker 1: dot com and on January 1st, you'll
get
Speaker 2: an email from me
Speaker 1: telling you exactly what
Speaker 2: to do to take advantage
Speaker 1: of this.
Speaker 2: It's it's crazy.
Hopefully, the
Speaker 1: IRS has no rules against outrageous
membership discounts because if they did,
we'd be screwed.
We'd be having to audit Central.
Speaker 2: Let me put it that way.
Or are it
Speaker 1: as Trump likes to call them?
Get on my newsletter David Pakman dot com
and you'll be notified January 1st.
Remember that the David Pakman show is primarily
funded by viewers and listeners like you through
the membership program on our website through
the end of the week.
If you get a new full price yearly membership
for 60 bucks, we'll send you a free T-shirt
of your choice six or seven different designs,
many sizes and colors available.
Sign up at Join Packman dot com free T-shirt
with a new
Speaker 2: full price yearly
Speaker 1: membership.
Just email info at David Pakman dot com.
After signing up